tell you what Eric Adams is doing a good
job if that's the
biggest if in your week in New York
youve seen bigger dicks on the subway
than you have Rats on the
subway you look like a fun group where
are you going after this I don't know
yet you don't know yet that's the type
of Carefree jiv that I really [__]
resent I look at this this youth this
optimism this who cares we're [__]
hot girls won't go
anywhere we don't even have our
ID that's very exciting that's New York
locals I'm from California from
California you just moved here
congratulations on moving to a
definitely better place this I used to
live in LA it's a [__] utter [__]
hole it really I know yeah you all
probably like sun but I'm British so you
know do you have a pension Chris no I
spent all my savings on Factor
he moved here from C why did you move
here from California for my job for your
job which is in finance in finance cool
that's [__] cool what's the
difference between Finance in California
and finance over here I feel like over
there it's probably worse is it right CU
they're just yeah maybe yeah like why
bother investing in bonds when you can
[__] surf a wave
bro your your air force ones are very
crisp and white as well I know and these
aren't though yeah I have a child she
[__] crayons on them I'm like what
are you doing um so and then your
friends here are they visiting from
California or are you local from you're
visiting from California how do you like
the city I love New York what's the
biggest rat you've seen so far like with
your
hands this big that's rubbish that's a
terrible R tell you what Eric Adams is
doing a good job if that's the
biggest if in your week in New York
you've seen bigger dicks on the subway
than you have Rats on the subway
that's really
good I love I love I love New York I'm
glad you like it and then and who's this
one hiding in the corner roommate
roommates okay cool stuff so do you did
you you've met just met tonight I guess
no no no that's
okay this is a a cool t-shirt what is
that a band or a TV show what's the deal
it's a movie it's a movie what does it
say creature oh Creature from the Black
Lagoon oh but it's got KI on so it's
it's a Japanese shirt of a [__] yeah
mate that's cool do you have one of
those body pillows
that the person who laughed and knows
what they are does do you know what body
pillows are they're like these long
pillows and they have sexy cartoon
characters on them and the idea is that
you sleep with them like this and you
[__] them as
well that's why he so strongly denied
that is this Partners wonderful stuff
does he have a body pillow though does
he yeah yeah that's good that's good you
don't look anything like a Japanese
school girl apologies if you are you
know hard hard to see with all the
lights and stuff so what what's What's
your deal you guys aren't from
California you local no we're from
Philadelphia Philadelphia that's quite
close isn't it that's close it's and
also not like California at all um what
what do you do uh I'm a mechanical
engineer that's that's cool he's a
mechanical engineer get get wet
ladies Grease Grease up yeah um what
what's your favorite thing to fix in my
head a mechanical engineer is someone
who changes tires that's what I think
maybe anywhere else it's not but if
they're from Philly I'm like you [__]
get under a car that's what you do you
just you've got a socket wrench and you
know how to use
it what what did you build what like
thermal and UV ma thermal and UV Ma
machines this man is going to kill all
of
us my best mate is Elon Musk and it's
basically a massive laser but don't
worry that's cool and then and then who
are you what you do um I work in quality
assurance quality assurance for his
murderous
lasers how how would you rate uh this
performance so far if you're 10 out of
10 oh thank you very much um it was too
high to be
believable when people come out like
you're my favorite comedian I'm like you
have [__] taste comedy mate when they
come go you're my eighth favorite
comedian I'm like that person is both
accurate and autistic that's not a thing
you ever
say quality assurance quality assurance
a Philadelphia mechanical engineer a
tech girl from La moving out to New York
and then we didn't even ask what what
you did what did you do I was in
operations in operations like
surgery is this for a startup oh okay
cool kind of and then that's for a start
someone over there's very very impressed
they're from Ohio they like yeah the
only thing I star is my combine
harvester
um what a Fun Bunch we've got here well
let's um let's celebrate you all Let's
uh let's enjoy all of you um California
girl what's your if you've got you know
a spare weekend what's your favorite
thing to
do go to bed go to bed all right with no
okay let's uh let's do this let's have
some fun let's celebrate these lovely
people uh the only way I know how cuz
you don't know this about me but I'm I'm
a rapper and I love to genuinely one
person just went really and the rest you
I am um so yeah you can you can hit that
Gina Jus holy [__] holy [__] [__]
he's really about to do it yes I about
to Freestyle that's making up a wrap on
the spot based on these lovely
people this is great we just met but
we're about to get to know them much
quicker with this it's going to be
lovely it's going to be fun what's your
name
Nicholas Jesus Christ I'm be picking
this I see Nicholas over there hand upon
his dick he's holding his shirt it's
like understand me Creature from the
Black Lagoon I got Ki I'm the Man shirts
from Japan 100% cotton I never approve a
bad on anyone import exporting I make
sure you be quality you're Shing got my
lady over here feeling silly she walks
around this is [__] why cuz we're in
Philly no quality completely devoid
going down there you're so annoyed like
how dare you say this to face I'm from
the Philly yo that's the best of the
place everybody knows it's the best by
far where am I under a car yes how I
like to relax you look at this see that
exhaust and Axle the caretta there's
none better for me actually I work with
the UV what does it mean yeah I'm beside
it you be talking that [__] with the
ultraviolet it's clear I'm the
mechanical engineer but the people
smoking all the weed they're here from
the West Coast they be feeling cocka
hoop see a dog over there and you know
the name Snoop what do you do on the
weekend rest your head I like to go
there sleep in my bed on the west coast
where the sunshine like to take a little
relax it's a fun time if I got some time
yes for myself you came to New York City
and risk your health you walk around to
hang with your friends like that how big
is this it's a tiny rant no one's ever
seen a they're numerous but this one
you've seen it's not voluminous very
very small a tiny little squeaker hear
in the beat coming there from the
speaker I love this look at these faces
and your roommate hiding in the places
are you staying in the place did you
bring her along like yeah that's fun
you're going to get along you were
moving in finance off to the east why
California pull of those beasts who rep
the cars there in the Beverly Hills they
sent you here for those wintry chills
you're going to be cold but you'll be
smiling you make it up as you go cuz
you're freestyling where do we go after
the show who cares guys who even knows
we're going to walk over here going to
have fun shot shot shot like another one
that's what you want to do oh maybe see
a man a guy who's obsessed with the
things from Japan we're going to hang
there never feel so shy cuz in his bed
he's got a pillow shaped like a
body